a Dancing with the Stars baby is on the  way  et has learned Maksim Chmerkovskiy and  Peta Murgatroyd are expecting their  first child a source close to the show  tells ET the engaged couple is quote so  happy funny thing is they've been trying  to get pregnant even before they were  engaged the news comes just one day  after PETA was crowned to the season 22  champ Max and Peter got engaged to back  in December and just days later the  dancing pros opened up to ET about the  magic moment everybody had an amazing  moment that that is very unforgettable  and you know I guess things like this  needs to be unforgettable there needs to  be special so I don't know how I did it  but I told I'm not planning anything  else I'm done zero I can say okay sure  whatever you'll just give the go-ahead